okay first of all I think that's big
enough
that's the repo for this talk and the
other reason I'm giving this repo out
right now is because let me find my
with my finger so there is a binder link
that is not working with his binder
crashed this morning and so it didn't
actually make my daugher image it only
just came back on like 10 minutes ago I
was getting gratefully not found for
most of the morning the collab link does
work it won't show you the slides but
will give you the notebook so you can
follow along so if you go there and
click on the collab link there is
actually a that there is a live notebook
on the Google collab oh sure
so web feet is my username and PI data
Miami in camel case
okay
you feel most doctor thinking okay
okay so on that note let's get started
so I'm gonna start so this is a really
big crowd I wasn't expecting you know
wall-to-wall audience here so this is
gonna be interest for me to put my head
on a pivot I'm much more used to
teaching long rooms than white rooms
really quick show of hands since we're
at PI data how many how many of you are
more than novices so intermediate or
higher in Python not pi data but Python
how many of you are beginners how many
you started this week with Python yeah
does it beef you first me so let's see
here three months of Python more than
three months less than three much more
than three months okay so other group is
the one I'm worried about less than
three months so not too many so you'll
follow along I won't make it too crazy
because I have to make certain
assumptions because it is 90 minutes and
compressed so first of all quick
introduction my name is avi jet I flew
down here from DC I have my own I'm a
consultant in the data science
consultant in DC and I also do a lot of
teaching through district data labs who
has a booth down this hall and I saw
Tony hanging out in the back somewhere
who's the head of district data labs we
do a lot of training in in data science
using Python and R so today I'll be
talking about sort of one package mainly
it's called pandas which has nothing to
do with the cute furry animal it has
ever you do it
it's Python for data analysis the
founder the the benevolent dictator for
life for pandas will be here tomorrow
giving a keynote West McKinney so
someone was like scaring it is he's
gonna be in here today so come see
so pandas actually changed the game in
terms of statistical analysis in part
so before that just a little bit of
context in history there were packages
called numpy and Syfy and matplotlib
which were done in the 90s and we're
very popular but they were primarily
meant to be a replacement for MATLAB for
those of you still use MATLAB for
numerical analysis so what's wrong with
that MATLAB is a perfectly good
prototype to float on well the issue is
that MATLAB assumed that you are dealing
only with numerical data because you're
only an engineer and so in reality as
people came to realize data is
heterogeneous so you can have text data
and numeric data and indicator data in
the same data in the same Excel
spreadsheet if you will in the same
table and now we've gone even further
say you can have images in the same data
you can have webpages in the same data
so answer is very heterogeneous but
we're going to deal with those kinds of
sort of bigger data clumps what pandas
did is it created structures to allow
heterogeneous data to stay together
which is really really useful when
you're thinking about data analysis
because it brought you back to what
you're familiar with in Excel in terms
of a rectangular sheet of data that
stays together and if you've ever tried
importing heterogeneous data in MATLAB
or go in numpy see if that's actually a
splitter we'll find out it created two
separate data objects one for the
numeric stuff one from the non numeric
stuff and now you have a problem because
you can't easily match them right
because no one is like all that all the
numeric data but then everything else is
missing whether it's text and vice versa
so we have to go through some of this
let's slowly get going
so the tools that I'm using today are
based on the Anaconda Python
distribution if you're not using the
anaconda Python distribution for doing
data work what's wrong with you frankly
there are competitors I mean an thought
has a perfectly good distribution and
you can download Python pure Python from
python.org and if you haven't if you
have a Mac you already have Python on it
so why everything in a compact anaconda
was set up as a bundle meant for data
science it got all the right packages
together and it's easy to install is
easy to upgrade and it runs on all the
three major OSS so it makes like very
very easy as well maintained no it's not
a splitter I didn't think of this but
here so so the two main packages I'll be
dealing with today are pandas which I've
already mentioned the title and I'm
using a particular version because
there's a certain changes over time I'm
also using Seabourn Seabourn is a data
visualization library it's and when we
get to that towards the end of the talk
I'll talk a little bit more about it I
will still be using numpy in this talk
because numpy is the base layer on which
all computation all scientific
computation is built in Python and
pandas is on top of that okay so you
still need to go down to numpy it at
some point side pies and other packages
I realized I'm actually not using
because I took a section away so numb
points out the bottom three here numpy
sci-fi and math what life were the
original PI data stack and then we got
pandas and then we got stats models
which is the modeling side of things
scikit-learn which is the machine
learning side of things there's other
psychics psychic imagery is the image
analysis and ltk which is the natural
language processing and they're all sort
of together now and so you realize if
you go down to the end of the hall to
that table with all the stickers and
raising almost all the stickers are for
data analysis packet
just in different contexts you realize
how much this has grown in the last ten
years we're talking about the very we're
talking about the baby steps in getting
into that today so I've got few
objectives and we'll see whether we get
through them I'm gonna concentrate on
pandas because I think that's what's
more important pandas is really a tool
for data ingestion and data munging what
does that mean you have data stored in
some way shape or form that you got from
an experiment from a colleague from
scraping the web from whatever and you
need to put bring that into Python
that's one of the big roles of pandas
has and munching means transforming this
data in different ways and we'll talk
about different ways of transformation
to make the data useful for analysis raw
data is almost never useful for analysis
you actually have to transform it into a
way that other functions can actually
work on it so you want to go from a raw
data set to an analytic data set and
there's and pandas is the big toolbox to
do that so we'll talk a little bit about
data cleaning mainly about missing
values transforming data sets as I said
we'll talk about the split apply
combined paradigm or the group by
paradigm or MapReduce however you want
to think about that particular paradigm
is the same thing and then doing data
summaries so pandas is really not about
modeling at all it's about getting data
to a state where you can model on it
the next objective is to look at some
flooding so matplotlib is the old
granddaddy if any of you have used
MATLAB you'll be very comfortable in
math but like there's almost the same
syntax
unfortunately it that what that means
that makes certain kinds of plots very
very ferbos to write and so see burn was
is one of many visualization packages
out there right now where Seabourn
specifically created for statistical
data representations and makes certain
things very very easy it's still raw so
just as pandas are sitting on top of
numpy see you burn is sitting on top of
math math live so you can go down if you
want but the top players often the
easier way to go and we'll go through a
different kinds of graphs that we need
that we can play around with and we'll
if we have time we'll talk a little bit
about statistical modeling I don't think
we'll have that much time but we'll see
how we go how it goes
okay so we're turning up so let this is
part of my first question I assume we
know the basics of Python so you know
how to turn on the Python interpreter
you know how to turn on notebook you
know how to write basic things I'm going
to revoke review to particular
structures that are actually very useful
both in data analysis as well as in
talking to pandas in some sense and
their lists and dictionaries or dates
and I always make the distinction that
lists are square brackets and dicks are
curly braces there's also one more that
a magnetic bar which is tuples which are
the round parentheses and everyone gets
confused when you start off with Python
so what's what so we're only going to
talk about the squares and the Curly's
today
so list
our very simple concept there there
about it they will contain they will
carry anything and however many of them
you like with you so it's literally a
bucket the members of this can be of any
kind of object so it could be a number
it could be another list it could be
another dictionary it could be a text
you know the sequence of text it could
be whatever you like so lists are
completely heterogeneous in terms of
their content but they are ordered in
that there is a sense of what's the
first element was the second element was
the third element and that's important
to think about so there is a beginning
and an end to a list so for example this
is a very simple list I'm probably have
to blow this up a little bit you realize
this is quite small I'm sorry
that better in the back I know we're not
very deep but I know in the corners can
probably gonna still have to squint
that's a that's a ways maybe one more up
okay so this is a very simple kind of a
list where I have a string another
string a number and a boolean a boolean
is a yes/no is a true/false variable
it's a special kind of variable if
you're not very familiar with Python one
things you will realize very quickly
with programming most programming is
case-sensitive so true has to have a
capital T in it and small R small use
small e same and same with false so
these are just two lists which have the
same structure essentially
and so there's a sense of what the first
element is so from l1 the first element
is my first name now one thing you'll
notice right now as I said it's a zero
at element so Python starts counting at
zero if an even and if you have done R
or I've done God for a bit Fortran way
back when
those charts with 1c starts with zero
Python starts with zero I think Java
start to zero as well so this is a zero
base index similarly you can grab parts
in the middle which is called slicing so
you can say 1 colon 3 so on look it
appears as if this would give me 3
elements but it only gives me 2 so one
of the semantics and Python that are
that's important is that when you see
this colon notations of 1 column 3 1
colon 3 it means it takes the first one
but does not take the last one so 1
colon 3 really means 1 and 2 so it's up
to 3 so this only gives me the second
one which is bergman and the third
element which is the number 43 so this
is something that's important to
remember for 90% of the time there's a
big abran case inside pandas where this
what that convention does not hold and
it does the natural thing of agitating
both ends so as I scroll so this is so a
colon B means you include a but stop the
for B so if it was two colons six that
really means it's two three four and
five no six
so if you want to structurally beginning
you can just do : 3 which would be 0 1 &
2 ok then I seen in pythons you can also
start counting from the right in that
you can write L 2 minus 2 okay the less
element is also minus 1 so the rightmost
element is minus 1 and so minus 2 is 1
to the left of that so that's why it
comes to 43 which is this this false
would have been the minus 1 at element
this is the minus second element that'll
be the - Turo Gamez so you can go either
way and you can slice either way you can
also replace elements you know lists so
you can just say that that this element
here I'm going to now change to 49 and
so if you print it out it actually
changes the original list so lists are
mutable in that even once you've created
it it's not set in stone
you can keep changing elements of it you
can add to it you can subtract from it
you can change it you know it's lists
are probably the most flexible object
and in Python dictionaries are the other
really nice structure that I use a lot
and they're essentially key value pairs
you have a key and you have a value
there's some restrictions on what can be
a key a key can be a string should be
literally a word in quotes it can be a
number or it can be what are called
tuples so tuples are the third kind of
thing I talked about which is the round
braces think of tuple as a fixed list
once you've created it you can't change
it it's set in stone I'm not gonna use
tuples at all so I'm not gonna worry
about it today
values just as list in DNA it could be
another list you could be another
dictionary it could be whatever the
other important thing is there is no
ordering right and so this is a very
similar
dictionary very similar to the list I
made but now you notice there's pear so
first gets a value last gets a value so
the key is first the value is Allegiant
the key is first the value is Tracey and
so on and so forth so I can call
elements by key so if I did d1 and I
gave it the key it gives me the value
note if I change this to say okay it's
the first things I'm going to Dez row
d-10 I try and run that it gives me an
error saying oh I didn't run this first
that's right so that's the wrong error
so it says Kiara zero so it can't find
zero among the keys so there's no sense
of a first element or a second element
or third element however just to make it
just that much more confusing you can
have keys to be 0 1 & 2 and so on so you
could have a d-10 if one of the keys was
0 so for example if I change this back
to 0 which is valid and then that gives
me a value so just to make things just a
little bit more confusing yeah you know
actually that's probably not true so
let's try this because I think this is
true
no that does not work okay so it doesn't
have an attribute so you can do this for
so this is the only way to call a
dictionary value if something that
actually works so Python has a core
group of functions which is the core
Python but it's been expanded using
packages as is almost every sensible
programming language in the world
most of the patents are traditionally
used to load packages using a command
called pip and you get it from a
repository called pi PI anaconda uses a
different system which is called Conda
which in many ways is more comfortable
to use I guess and they have their own
repository essentially equivalent in
many ways so the package that I'm
installing to you today if you use the
anaconda distribution we're already
install so you didn't have to do a Conda
install anything and so the typical
command is import the package but you
can import the package as something as
you can alias it why because we're all
lazy typers this is fine until you
starting into beautiful soup and sequel
alchemy and really don't want to write
that over and over again or MATLAB like
dot PI plus it sold fast right and so
you a Lea sit and these are almost these
are standard aliases in the in the field
so numb pi is almost always envied
pandas is PD Seaborn is SNS don't tell
me don't ask me how these came about
that they came about and that's what
everyone uses
and so what's the package a package is
basically a group of functions the
modules technically if you want to look
at the nominal culture but they're
essentially groups of functions that are
put together that you can access from
the package for particular purposes and
the way you grab them is you do package
dot function if there's sub modules that
you'd be package dot module dot function
we'll see a couple of those as well but
basically there's a dot notation so when
you're naming your variables in a
program as a programming language
don't use dot dot is protected right we
forget this sometimes we think that
that's easy so the convention is
typically camelcase or pathologies
partial cases if you join words by
underscores and camel cases temple
wherever so for example I'm taking this
list l1 that I created a few slides ago
and I'm making it into an umpire race or
NP is my alias for numpy within that
there is a function array which
transforms this list into this array
which is essentially has the same
content but it has some more structure
to it one of the things that you will
notice in this array that's written in
out 51 is that the number 47 and the
boolean true are not quoted remember
when I started as I said in math that
math lab had this problem that it means
in it homogeneous data sets numbers stay
with numbers and non numbers stay with
non numbers well what happened here is
that it seemed there's two things that
are non number so they make everything
non numbers everything is drained and so
we just lost information by doing this
right because now suddenly you've got
you know a character a string which it
should be a number and a string or it
should be a yes/no
so that was all the problems with sort
of heterogeneous data and enum fight and
this is true throughout numpy all non PI
arrays are homogeneous so be the
one-dimensional two-dimensional however
which is which can be great because if
you're just using numerical data you can
do a lot of stuff very fast with non
fine
if you're dealing in the real world with
heterogeneous data okay our metadata or
stuff like that it's a pain in the ass
oh why do one of the things you're
realizing as I'm because I'm realizing
as I'm typing my cells are actually live
so I'm using a Python package blow-dries
R is e which takes a notebook and
transforms it into slides but it keeps
the live notebook underneath so I can
type and run stuff it's very cool and
actually if you actually download my
github and you install rice on your own
computer you couldn't get the same
effect
okay so onto pandas which
the reason I chose this particular
picture of a panda because pandas is
meant to make things easier so we can
have more time to laze around West I was
just reading a interview that West
McKinney gave in 2017 where he is saying
that the biggest reason for doing pandas
is to make things easier for people so
you can write two lines of code instead
of 25 so you want to become a lazy panda
of course your boss will say well since
you're so efficient now you can do ten
times to work no but nonetheless so it
builds off of numpy so I showed you a
one dimensional array that in pandas
becomes a series the series is still
needs to be homogeneous but it actually
has some other metadata with it that
makes it interesting and a
two-dimensional numpy array which
traditional would be called a matrix is
in pandas called the data frame the name
data frame is not accidental it mimics
ours data frame object which is the
first one that actually allowed
heterogeneous rectangular data sets and
the data frame object is really what
transformed Python into a data analytic
language in my opinion it was a
scientific computing environment before
with numpy it is now a data analytic
environment which is broader to my
opinion
so I can just take that list and make it
a series this stays homogeneous but what
adds to it is it you get these zero one
two and three which are literally labels
the row names so you can actually change
the 0 1 2 3 2 ABCD whatever you like
that makes sense so the series object
starts putting metadata onto your
original data in the form of in what in
pandas is called index you can think of
it as row native names or whatever so
it's a label and this can be useful I
mean the series so pandas historically
was used for time series data because
West McKinney used to work on Wall
Street and use interest in the stock
ticker and so the labels used to be the
dates and you were talking about series
of stocks right and so you can literally
pull off a date just by its label the
data for a date
data frame is a bit different and I
think it's the biggest game-changer that
that brought but that's why we have
Idina conferences it's the data frame
you have to think about as a collection
of columns so if you think of think of a
data frame like an excel sheet if that
makes it easier for you to think about
but the structure is columnar so you
think of each column as a separate
entity and you've bunch these columns
together so each column is a series so
this is a bunch of series which means
each column has to be at the same type
but different columns can be of
different types so you could have you
live without the phone directory in a
data frame right you're gonna have the
name street name city state zip place is
a number but you should not keep us a
number because anyone here from the
Northeast from Boston you have a 0 in
the front so that's always a problem and
then you can add a telephone number to
it or however so you it's a homogeneous
there's a heterogeneous database that
you can put into one rectangular sheet
and so one of the ways you can create a
data frame I created these two
dictionaries and put them together since
they have the same names so the keys are
the same those keys become the column
names so I had age first last and mail
it ends up being arranged alphabetically
as you notice you can change that later
the formatting is a function of the
notebook it's not a function of this is
not what you'd see on a console great it
also gives you the row labels so these
are still the index of the data frame
and these are the columns of the data
frame let's see why a queue brandade
impeding on different okay I'm gonna go
back for just one sec because I need you
I'm just going back to where I loaded
especially the ones that we go
so with this one of the problems with
running a notebook and if any of you
follow Joel gross on the interwebs Joel
wrote a really nice book called data
science from the command line but he's
been very loud in the last two years
about saying notebooks are not the way
to go and this is the reason if it went
through and didn't do certain cells
there's dependencies and if you do
things in different orders look at
different results so it's it can be
awkward no changes pandas dataframe
pardon you just change it to like PS no
bicep to import pandas the import hadn't
happens the scope the scope isn't the
entire thing but if I didn't run it
before I just showed it to you right I
didn't actually run it so I went back to
run it and now if I run this it works
because it also ran the cell that had do
you wanted me to in it but I've been
skipping over stuff I'm not running
everything and so it's like oh you
didn't run so I don't know what that was
because you write linearly right
so there's a couple of things you can do
here so DF
started need
columns so the columns extracts out the
column headers which were the keys and
index grabs out the row names so in this
case is just 0 and 1 so saying there's a
special object called range indexes it
start at 0 and the 2 by ones but even
look at it the types here so if I did DF
info it tells me a bunch of things so
the index is a range index 0 to 1 the
columns
there's column table last column about
the age of conquered male and Colin pod
first the 0 is the is with the index so
hand isn't numpy sort of non play is
actually sort of weird because the
objects the types here that you're
seeing an object in 64 and all of this
those are actually coming from numpy
because it's based on vampire numpy
there's no good string object and so all
the string objects just be are called
object age of course is the integer and
male is a boolean it's just a true/false
so whenever you see an opera a type
object in pandas just assume that it's a
character variable does that's a
surrogate they're using
so there's different ways of trading
data frames and like I said this is
going to be very short we have a very
short time period
the pandas documentation is actually
fantastic so if you have questions about
anything here
you certainly reach out to me but you
can also go to the pandas documentation
it's actually quite good you can create
a frame from an umpire array or from a
single dictionary where you have arrays
now the crucial thing here for so what's
the geometric nature of a data frame
it's a rectangle right which means every
element every column has to be at the
same length so if I create a dictionary
that had first has three elements last
three elements and each had two elements
it would not be a data frame right
because they're not all the same length
so you have to ensure of that in this
case one of the things I did sort of
foreshadowing is since John Lennon's
actually did I put his age as a missing
value which is an object in numpy called
nain
for not a number and so it shows up in
my database as na N and we'll talk about
missing values as we go forward but I
intentionally pry it up here to expose
it to it so I put this in but typically
what will happen is you get add a set
date sets are never complete if you have
a complete data set is probably came
from a book and it's seriously
so you'll see missing values often in
the wild and so just getting to show you
one so hand this so I'm gonna make this
a little smaller because otherwise this
won't show
so if you think of this picture as sort
of the entire pipeline of data analysis
right
you start with grabbing data
transforming it doing some analysis
doing some modeling and then reporting
and then and then repeat right as you
get new data pandas lives in these first
two parts is before the function of
algorithms and the modeling and the like
this is just to get your data ready and
so let's start off with that first piece
which is data ingestion does that mean
it means you've got your data from
somewhere you have to put up you have to
put it into Python so pandas has a bunch
of functions that can read data from
most kinds of data sets that you will
actually ever get and they're
essentially wrappers around other things
but that doesn't matter what's important
and what makes band is really nice to
use is that they use the same kind of
language so to read anything it's PD dot
re underscore something that's a general
format for it right so PD for pandas so
pandas is a package within that there is
a read underscore something that'll read
a certain kind of file so you can
imagine for CSV files
how much separated values there's a read
underscore CSV for Excel there is a read
underscore Excel
you